The story of me,
Take 2.
Director:
3...
2...
Director:
Here we go, ready and...
Action!
♪♪
Wait a minute, Doc.
Uh...
Are you telling me that you
built a "Time machine",
Michael J. Fox:
Out of a DeLorean?
Davis Guggebheim:
What did it mean to be still?
I wouldn't know, I was never
still.
♪♪
Man:
That's him. That's our star.
Michael J. Fox:
I want this job. I can do it.
Whatever the exception is I can
fix it.
I can be "Holder", I can be
taller.
(Flash)
Michael J. Fox:
I can be anything.
Reporter:
The popularity of Michael J. Fox
is a phenomenon.
♪♪
Announcer:
Here is Michael J. Fox!
-(Crowd Applause)
Man:
What is the secret of your
success?
Man:
And the winner is.
Lady:
Michael J. Fox!
I don't believe this!
This is great.
(Crowd Applauding)
I feel four feet tall.
(Crowd sighs)
I get it. I was, big.
I was bigger than bubblegum.
♪♪
Michael J. Fox:
I woke up and I noticed my
pinky.
♪♪
Michael J. Fox:
Auto animated.
♪♪
Michael J. Fox:
Parkinson's disease.
I told Tracy the news.
Michael J. Fox:
In sickness and in health, I
remember her whispering.
♪♪
Michael J. Fox:
No one outside of my family
knew.
Michael J. Fox:
There was only one reason I took
these pills...
Michael J. Fox:
to hide.
♪♪
But all those years of
hiding...
was shaking me awake.
♪I closed my eyes and I slipped
away♪
♪♪
Michael J. Fox:
To deny that part of me that
wants to continue to go on
and do things, is-is to quit.
I won't accept that!
♪It's more than a feeling♪
♪More than a feeling♪
♪When I hear that old song they
used to play♪
Michael J. Fox:
That's... this is what I am.
♪♪
I'm a tough, uh,
son of a bitch.
Davis Guggenheim:
The sad sack story is... Michael
J. Fox gets this debilitating
Davis Guggenheim:
disease, and it crushes him.
Yeah, that's boring.
♪It's more than a feeling♪
♪♪
♪Til I see Marianne walk away♪